all right I am NOT in my place of
normalcy I'm in Miami it's time for one
super Wednesday and today I'm going to
be reviewing the Grammy's fashions I
swear one super Wednesday is not just
gonna be a fashion reviews it just so
happens that there have been a lot of
red carpet events lately so stick it up
your butt and deal with it first off we
have that's Katy Perry what who did that
on you that looks like beautiful musical
tissue and your face looks like you love
it so cute pink you look great in red
pink gee it looks like one she'd be
super fun to get drunk with and two she
would beat the [ __ ] out of anyone that
may fun with me Taylor Swift
someone put a Tiffany fishnet over top
of her Beyonce I won't be on say that
everything about this is great - don't
you look like a doily I wanna Sara
Bareilles someone put a bunch of tampons
on the dress you wore it out you know
what I don't hate it
I'm gonna see you be brave Randall
tampons tiara - some Victorian drapes
and the like
I'm a house of cards what Paris all
truth is there of course music icon
Paris Hilton she's gonna go to the ice
rink and then get married in the
eighties Alicia Keys just staring
directly into the chesticles she got two
great keys ariana grande with her
classic oh my face I can't hang on
there's just got so much hair she looks
like she's going to an Easter brunch
with her dad who's taking this photo and
making her post Madonna will be playing
the role of Diane Keaton tonight
googling kids just like Dick Tracy
but the dick got tough tonight well
there you go
the Grammys fashion reviews I give it
two and a half to three things let's
figure them out mentally out of five so
pretty cool I don't know
do not like
do not like please stop
oh great okay
I literally just ran back to my hotel
room from a dinner because I forgot that
I did not mention Pharrell and the thing
he did at the Grammys you know it I know
it I don't know how to
four really feel about it
I love him no matter what
I love him no matter or hat
hat
that hat though